c'est elle qui conduira la liste et
réinventons elancourt aux prochaines
élections municipales élan courtoise
depuis plus de 30 ans catherine perron
temps raufast et médecins le collectif
qui l'a désigné est composé de militants
politiques associatifs et de citoyen
elancourt que j'aime beaucoup c'est ma
ville a beaucoup changé et l'encours est
devenue une ville morne endormi où il ne
se passe plus rien
pour moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
que les habitants puissent reprendre en
main leur ville
réinventons élan coût est une liste
participatif qui défendent des valeurs
de gauche
pour cette nouvelle réunion près de 80
personnes avaient fait le déplacement à
la maison de quartier de la ville dieu
c'est l'avenir c'est ce que les gens
recherchent en ce moment ils en ont
marre des prises de décisions
centralisée donc ils ont besoin d'avoir
un tracteur de leur propre destin et de
leurs décisions
donc c'est l'intérêt de ces listes que
tout le monde puisse y trouver son
compte et et avoir un vrai intérêt à y
participer
je suis dans les jardins familiaux des
quatre arbres qui sont menacées de
destruction depuis plusieurs années par
la mairie et là j'ai trouvé une liste
qui s'engagent à les préserver et même à
les agrandir
donc c'était la raison du pourquoi je
suis venu cet après midi même si le
programme est encore en cours
d'élaboration les principaux ponts
étaient présentés lors de cette réunion
tous nos axes c'est démocratie
participative transition écologique est
une ville pour tous les âges pour tous
les quartiers pour tous les besoins
autre projet évoqué l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt dans une perspective
verte ou encore une gestion raisonnée